I do freestyle rap that's rap that you
make up it's improvised it's not written
or prepared it's based on what you want
to hear a rap battle we'll take five
suggestions and we'll divide you guys up
so everyone gets a fair go so is that
the second thing you said did you say
did you say Putin's penis
no no no Putin's penis I'm good with
well that's the suggestion from the kind
of middle section I guess so back let's
come to the let's come to the back of
the room because you were hollering what
would you like to stretch about back of
the room
oh
yes that's we've I mean I'm hesitant to
say that I've taken that already because
that
I like to leave some mystery there yeah
so that's suggestion number one don't
worry Putin's penis will be in the wrap
back of the room you can suggest just
suggestion number two what would you
like a wrapper
puppetry puppetry thank you puppetry
that's yeah you don't really think about
it much too but
it is still an art is it an art
[Applause]
prostate exams okay
okay well we've got two more suggestions
to fill we're gonna come to this side
and this side we'll come to this side
first what would you like a rapper
really [__] so you you said math and
you said Billy Joel eating [__]
so yeah I know
sorry
the thing is in my country math is
called math so already you put my back
up whereas in my country we also say
Billy Joel eating [__] it's the same
thing and then the final suggestion will
come from over here What's it gonna be
a bachelorette it's you know
congratulations but it's not the most
creative thing is it no it's not it's
not beating Billy Joel eating [__]
can I just ask are you with the
bachelorette party
now he is okay okay a bachelorette
cutting her toenails Billy Joel eating
[__] puppetry yeah I remembered
prostate exam as well and Putin's penis
right
well I'll try and remember all five of
them if I forget Putin's penis then
there's gonna be a [__] riot over
there
um red and Jeremy I would love it if you
would furnish me with some musical
accompaniment there they're gonna make
up a beat I'm gonna make of a wrap it
will be as good as the suggestions so
I don't know this beautiful Soulful well
let's let's do this
[Music]
you know what can you
can you rap bunch of ladies going crazy
maybe after take the shots of vodka
causing that disaster but don't worry I
know my bro will never fail down on one
knee not proposing but toenail flipping
taking out a fire and an emery board
he's getting down at the edges you'll
never get caught in your tights again
and start a ladder when it comes to
toenails there's none badder than the
guy maybe he'll give you a manicure the
man is pretty sure he'd be down on the
floor light oh yes usually I'm so tough
masculine but asking the toenail buff
this looks like I'm wanking off a
Russian guy even though his dick would
not be this High maybe down here I see
him shooting a hand job mine for
Vladimir Putin is this illegal is this a
crime would he send me to small lengths
to do some hard labor time in a camp or
just one between the eyes Putin's penis
said by this guy that's in your brain
please answer me is that some type of
Twisted Fantasy that you're glad to see
ever so glad you asked one plus one
there we go that's the mass number two
moving on from you say it properly with
mathematics if I see Billy Joel here
he's got it down on the floor like the
guy with the toes MSG doing Madison
shows he's at the Garden you can go and
see him play all the lovely songs that
he does and he says and let me say this
the rappers never planned the only Billy
Joel song I know is Piano Man and no
[__] others I've never even got any
knowledge but still when he's got his
tongue in I acknowledge he's a master he
can go left and right Billy Joe could
eat your [__] eat box all night maybe
making all the ladies wet you'd invite
Billy Joel to The Bachelorette but it's
kind of weird the irony to say he eats
box when his initials are BJ surely he
should suck [__] that's a [__] anyway
puppetry is so odd to see a grown man
put their animals on hands walking in
like yes I don't understand Punch and
Judy is truly my passion got a crocodile
policeman there clashing like he's just
uses his fingers if you want to do some
puppetry and they're in there of course
the best puppetry that's so great is
puppeteera man when you examine his
prostate
[Applause]